good morning welcome to our continuation
of Constitution Day celebration I'm glad
to see you all found the room I know we
were all wondering about the fertilizer
Institute and I did know it I'm sure you
did as well it's not just any convention
it is the world convention of fertilizer
and we all know that that's appropriate
that it be held in Washington DC where
one can always find lots of shiitake
mushrooms we have two great panels this
morning both built around speakers who
are at Hillsdale collagen have written
great books and our first panel this
morning will be moderated by Ronald post
read Oh dr. pretory tOA's Dean of the
Graduate School his statesmanship at
Hillsdale College where he holds the
Charles and Lucia Shipley chair and
American Constitution he serves as a
senior fellow at the Kirby Center here
in Washington and is also senior fellow
at the Claremont Institute here it's BA
at Clark McKenna College and his MA and
PhD at the Claremont Graduate School
he's the author of several works Woodrow
Wilson and the roots of American
liberalism and he's he is also the
editor of Woodrow Wilson the essential
political rights doctor post Rita
[Applause]
Thank You Matt and thanks to Doug
Jeffrey and to Matt for inviting me to
be with you this morning our first panel
will be a discussion of my colleague Tom
West's new book titled the political
theory of the American Founding natural
rights public policy and the moral
conditions of freedom and I've been very
much looking forward to this panel for
some time since of course dr. West is
one of our own at Hillsdale and since I
really think that his his new book is
very much destined to become one of the
most important scholarly treatments of
the founding in our time in the book the
political theory of the American
Founding Tom provides a complete
overview of the American founders
political theory the book is intended as
a response to the current scholarly
consensus and that consensus holds that
the founders political thought is best
understood as a kind of amalgam or
combination of liberalism republicanism
and other traditions and dr. West argues
on the contrary that the foundational
documents of our founding overwhelmingly
point to natural rights as the lens
through which all of the politics of the
founding can be understood now
one difficulty with a panel on a new
book is that many here may not yet have
read it although it would encourage you
all to do so so what we're going to do
is begin with dr. West himself and he
will give a presentation of the books
argument and then we'll follow with
commentaries from the other panelists so
I'll introduce everyone here in the
order that that they will be speaking so
we'll begin with dr. Tom West he teaches
in hills dales politics department as
the Paul Irvine Potter and Dawn Tibbets
Potter professor of politics and among
his many books and articles are an
earlier treatment of the founding
many of you may be familiar with titled
vindicating the founders as well as the
widely used for text on Socrates that
has an introduction by dr. West and
translations of Plato by dr. West and
his wife Hillsdale zone dr. grace starry
West following dr. West will be dr.
Patrick Danine dr. Dineen is associate
professor of political science at the
University of Notre Dame where he holds
the David a potentially tear of
constitutional studies his PhD is from
Rutgers University and his books include
the Odyssey of political theory
democratic faith conserving America and
the forthcoming book why liberalism
failed and that will be published with
the Yale University Press I'm told in
January concluding our our presentations
will be dr. Joshua Mitchell he's
professor of government at Georgetown
University he's the author of numerous
articles in his field and also of four
books the most recent of those is
Tocqueville in Arabia dilemmas in a
democratic age that was published by the
University of Chicago Press and dr.
Mitchell received his PhD from the
University of Chicago so we will begin
with dr. Tom West
[Applause]
Thank You RJ the I want to say something
first about the what some of the
characteristically characteristic
differences in my approach in this book
to what has been prevailed in the
scholarship that dominates the field so
far first of all I talk about the
founders simply from their own point of
view talk about fundamentally what their
documents say and what the principles
articulated in their official documents
were so which me that means I'm not
talking about where did the founders get
their ideas scholars tend to spend lots
of time on whether Locke was or was not
the evil genius behind the founders or
the hero as some would say whether
Protestantism etc I mean you can get
into these endless discussions of
provenance without talking about what
the Founding actually was secondly I
talk about throughout the book the
consensus of the founding as much as
possible as I say rely upon documents
approved by elected officials preferably
representative assemblies like town
meetings legislatures conventions and so
forth and so I pay very little attention
to what what was uniquely believed by
individual founders John Adams Jefferson
Madison and so forth in so far as those
founders help us understand the obit the
big picture I do quote them but as
illustrative to what the consensus
turned out to be third I spend lots of
time with documents from individual
states because as it turns out in the
founding the US Constitution did not
attempt to solve the question of
government as a whole all it did was to
set up a federal government and
allocated almost all domestic policy
decisions to state governments and one
of the almost shocking things about my
profession political science is how few
political scientists who teach the
founding ever get beyond the founding
documents at the federal level the
Federalist Papers Constitution
Declaration of Independence
those are truly indispensable but
without knowing what happened in state
governments and what they were saying
about politics and natural rights and
what government needs to do you will
miss out on about 80% or 90% of what the
founders thought government needed to do
to achieve its proper goal and then
finally my fourth distinctive aspect in
the book is I treat the founders
political thought as if it might be true
twenty years ago I published vindicating
the founders in which I defended the
founders I tried to make the case that
their argument was right but in the new
book I neither defend nor criticize I'm
really in this book I'm giving an
explanation
in fact I compared it to an archaeology
understanding the founding is
increasingly I put I've in my experience
like digging up old bones people don't
know anything about it they we hear the
slogans created equal consent of the
governed but we don't know the way they
thought of those things in the context
in which they understood them now what I
want to do in my in the next couple of
minutes is to is to say a little bit
about what the bulk of my book is about
namely how did the founders think
government should secure our natural
rights
that's what its purpose of government is
that but how what does the government
actually need to do in the first place
of its foreign policy which in the
founding has two guiding principles both
based on the natural rights natural law
theory of the founders one is of course
the government's there to secure your
rights by protecting them protecting you
protecting individual citizens against
violence coming from abroad that's to be
done by means of Armed Forces diplomacy
alliances whatever it might take and
this mandate in the Constitution's
preamble the common defense is the sole
purpose of foreign policy in the
founding then the second principle
foreign policy officer articulated early
in the declaration is the principle that
every nation has a right to a separate
and equal station in the world
that's the non-intervention principle or
the anti-imperialism principle what it
means is that the United States is that
the natural law forbids the United
States from interfering in the course
and affairs of other nations these two
principles I think it's fair to say
either no longer guide American foreign
policy or guide it only in some degree
because other concerns have become to
the fore in recent foreign policies such
as solving the problems of other nations
as deferred domestic policy governments
first duty here as in foreign policy is
to protect citizens against violence or
trespassing and this means especially
making and enforcing criminal laws
against harm to life liberty and
property this is what government is
supposed to do in fact Jefferson said
government would be remiss in its
principal purpose were it not to
restrain wicked and dissolute men who
commit violations on the lives liberties
and properties of others that's the
basic meaning of securing our rights in
the domestic policy arena in striking
contrast with Jefferson is today's
government's priorities let me give you
a few quotes in 2014 five years after
the discovery of 11,000 abandoned rape
evidence kits in Detroit only 2,000 of
those kits had undergone DNA testing
allowing serial rapists to remain free
and in some cases to commit more attacks
Memphis Tennessee had a backlog of
11,000 untested rape kits 12,000 in 2014
in Houston
20,000 burglary theft assault and
hit-and-run cases with workable leads
were not even investigated in 2013
Texas judges up until quite recently
have punished first-degree murder
commonly with probation and no prison
time these lapses which are
characteristic of governments throughout
the states are represent a tacit
rejection of the founders view that the
basic way government secures our rights
is through enforcement of criminal law
and those types of criminal laws we now
have the experience after the 2017
Charlottesville riot with people openly
arguing that citizens who have the wrong
political opinions do not deserve the
equal protection of the laws they do not
deserve to be protected by having by
thereby having criminal prosecutions
instituted against those who attack them
the in the founding in addition to the
criminal laws of the founding to protect
individuals and private associations
government has to implement civil laws
of various kinds for example on property
contracts and personal injury in in part
three of my book on property and
economics I explained how the natural
rights who acquire and possess property
can't be secured without an elaborate
legal infrastructure in the founders
view it is not enough to let to get
government out of the way
that's a common libertarian opinion of
our time which the founders completely
rejected property first first of all has
to be defined by government deeds have
to be recorded so that everyone knows in
a legal sense who owns what there have
to be clear legal standards for
contracts and reliable enforcement of
them in courts of law so that the right
to acquire property through training
through commerce can be properly
protected there must be a stable supply
of money for conducting exchanges on the
mark on the market which means
government had a responsibility to not
inflate the currency
and in the founders view government
should base its currency on a metallic
standard of gold silver or both lawsuits
for personal injury should be provided
for so that harms to people that are
less than crimes that are minor but
still real harms can be compensated
through the courts of law and in
addition to these to the criminal law
enforcement and civil laws of the type I
just mentioned there's a third kind of
law that the founders thought work was
important and that is more of laws to
promote the moral foundations of a free
government and I'll quote the Virginia
Bill of Rights on that quote no free
government or the blessings of liberty
can be preserved except by a firm
adherence to justice moderation
temperance frugality and virtue unquote
the many ways by which government does
that in the founding is the theme of the
many ways of the government does that
that's the theme of part two of my book
which is called the moral conditions of
freedom and these include laws on the
marriage and divorce which were designed
to promote stable marriages to make
divorce possible but rare they also
outlawed sex outside of marriage whether
heterosexual or homosexual although as I
discovered enforcement of those laws was
rather lacks in practice and in fact I
never found a single instance in the
founding in which a same-sex
relationship between adults was punished
by criminal law although was illegal in
every state fourth government has to
make some minimal provision for its poor
and that means and although for most
people the protection of the laws
protection of National Defense was
enough so that they could provide for
themselves through the industry
frugality and through family
relationships that wasn't always
possible there were problems with
orphans unemployment disability and
private institutions although they were
preferred we're not always available so
government always believed itself to be
the last resort to be needed to be
present as a last resort
take care of people's problems of that
type that when they were sufficiently
urgent but they did that in a very
differently from ours we think the way
to do that is to give people specific
benefits who if they are designated to
be sufficiently poor their idea was well
if you're sufficiently poor we will set
up a group home and you can come and
live there and you will be required to
work it's so far as you have the ability
to work the result was very few people
were ever run welfare in the whole in
the history of the nineteenth century
because being in the poorhouse was not a
very wonderful thing to be you typically
made efforts to get out of it as quickly
as you could and those who were
able-bodied aren't thanked and managed
to do so did so to conclude I want to
quote you all eleven a comment he made
on National Review Online
he said West begins from the depressing
but plausible premise that the thought
of the founders must be presented to
contemporary Americans as a novelty
because it is largely unknown so he
begins at the beginning and offers a
compelling case that the doctrine of
natural rights bounded by the moral
natural law was the core of the founders
political theory and adds leaven for
reasons that should still speak to us
thank you
[Applause]
well first I want to thank Hillsdale
College for the invitation to speak on
Tom wess book and for the opportunity to
read this really fine book and to thank
Tom for writing it I want to raise
questions I think I've been invited here
to raise questions about the book but I
want to do so in the context of a deep
appreciation of what West has
accomplished in this book it is a really
masterful study and analysis of the view
abroad as he puts it the founders
consensus and I learned much from
reading the book but the question I want
to raise really goes to the heart of the
claim of the book which is the view that
there was a consensus in some senses a
broad agreement among many different
voices at the time of the founding now
whenever one wants to reach a consensus
as we know from politics one often has
to smooth some edges one has to render
certain differences less evident and
while West provides a wealth of evidence
and a really stunning wealth of evidence
supporting expressions of expressions of
support of the natural rights philosophy
at the same time the book tends to leave
aside internal disagreements and debates
even within but also even outside of the
natural rights philosophy sometimes by
the same thinkers this as Tom has
indicated leads at times to needing to
dismiss particular claims by some of the
founding fathers so Madison Hamilton
Jefferson at times don't get the natural
rights philosophy right I'm in fact like
one of the things I learned was that
apparently Zephaniah Smith is the only
of the founding fathers unbeknownst to
me who seems to get everything right
Theophilus Parsons so these are our
actual founding fathers
they belong in our currency the effort
then to create to form this consensus
leads to certain lesions and the
glossing of challenges within even this
generation to the natural rights
philosophy not as is often posed by West
in the book from many contemporary
scholars and I represent perhaps one of
those but from the contemporaries at the
time of the founding and even some of
the people who West cites as having
supported as having given evidence of
supporting the natural rights philosophy
of the founders he omits for example
challenges to the basis of the natural
rights philosophy itself voices from the
founding period that opposed for example
the state of nature scenario so is
central to the natural rights philosophy
as as a false understanding of human
nature as presenting a false view of
human nature that our nature in our
natural condition we have to imagine
ourselves in a kind of pre political
condition in which in a sense everything
is defined by our rights
one such voice who is invoked by West in
one part of the book to support a view
of natural rights philosophy wasn't if
annual miles not very well-known member
of the founding generation but among
other things the author of of a set of
sermons an extraordinary set of sermons
at the time of the just before the
revolution 1774 in which he criticizes
premises of the natural rights
philosophy in the 1774 sermon at the
time of a rising invocation of the
philosophy of John Locke as a
justification of the Revolution he
writes in that sermon or spoke in that
sermon quote originally there were no
private interests he says to the extent
that there was a compact a first compact
that was made to secure or advance
private interests that compact he says
was made in your in usurpation he calls
in this sermon to the sub sub su mning
private interests to the common good
which is a characteristic call of many
in the congregational tradition of the
time of the founding echoing the
thoughts and words of John Winthrop he
has a line in which he says that each
person is only to enjoy his property at
the will of the community which is to be
regulated by the interest of the whole
this is somebody who again is is cited
by by West as a supporter of the natural
rights but one has to leave out a great
deal in order to reach that conclusion
and this is a characteristic expression
of some during this period but more
broadly a characteristic expression of a
hesitation about a full-throated embrace
of the natural rights philosophy and its
implications now such strong and
explicit criticisms of the natural right
philosophy were relatively rare but not
absent but the suspicion in particular
toward the private istic and corrupting
tendencies of the natural rights
philosophy was a common theme and
especially in response to the
Constitution as it was proposed
following the Constitutional Convention
it was especially a concern prevalent
among many of the so-called anti
federalists many of whom are cited again
by West when statements can be found of
their supporting the natural rights
philosophy but otherwise those
criticisms are left silent such authors
such anti-federalist critics of the
Constitution frequently articulated
concerns that the Constitution its
fundamental deeper philosophy once
actuated and overtime unfolding would
undermine both civic and personal virtue
and so while many of these authors used
the lexicon of the natural rights
philosophy in their in their view virtue
and morality was not understood as
serving the natural rights our private
concerns rather Republican government
was emphasized as a discipline of
self-rule and itself as serving of
morality in this sense we can say that
for the anti-federalist in many cases
happiness was not a matter of personal
choice but rather reflected a condition
a kind of objective condition closer to
Aristotelian understanding of eudaimonia
or
flourishing these authors warned that
the emphasis especially upon the private
aspects of the natural right philosophy
particularly the emphasis upon personal
liberty private property rights and the
freedom to dispose of those private
rights not only a herring and the
property we own but in ourselves that
this would have the tendency over time
of it of undermining civic and personal
virtue among the things argued by many
of these authors against some of whom
are invoked by West as reflecting
support of this consensus favored more
constraints for example on markets
especially out of a concern for what
they thought would be the rise of luxury
the development of a disposition to
desire material goods and even desire
prosperity that would lead to attendant
losses of liberty political Liberty the
submission to economic powers maybe even
bowing to foreign potentates and the
personal loss of virtue which in the
form of slavish desires what we might
today called consumerism that is to say
there was an extensive contemporary
awareness that the natural rights
philosophy if left unchecked would tend
over time toward the corruption of
morals and the same kind of concerns
were expressed as well about the
political organization itself of the
Constitution the tendency to centralize
power the tendency of representatives
and representation in Washington to
become more distant from the people the
tendency over time to identify more with
the national interest as opposed to
those local state interests all of these
concerns were expressed at the time of
the American Founding not by scholars
not only by some scholars today but by
the contemporaries in many cases those
invoked by West these critiques and
concerns have remained a constant
throughout American history they're as
much a part of our founding as our
founding even if they've often been
submerged concerns during the Jacksonian
period the rise of an agrarian set of
interests in America the populist up
right
and today evinced in such movements as
the Tea Party and even perhaps in the
electorate that elected Donald Trump
it's seen today in the misgivings over
globalization and the concerns today
over whether or not globalization
undermines an important form of
self-rule reflects a kind of division
today that that persists that we see at
the time of the American Founding
whether certain virtues could be
cultivated if economic concerns and
interests took the foremost West's
religions and certain silences
contributes to his smoothing that
results in an apparently seamless
relationship of morality and the natural
rights philosophy that is reflected in
the inclusion of part two that he
mentions of his book the moral condition
of freedom and I think this is this is
really an extraordinary piece of writing
a very learned
piece of writing and I think the most
intriguing and original part of the book
spending a lot of time looking at the
policies and concerns in the moral realm
as a period of the founding fathers and
yet I think this part of the book is
least convincing and connecting the
fundamental philosophical commitments of
the natural rights philosophy and the
promotion of morality that existed at
the time throughout the section West
argues that morality was promoted or
under or understood to be supporting the
natural rights philosophy ourselves as
rights bearing individuals that it
provides as he often states the rights
infrastructure that makes possible the
success of a natural rights Republic in
other words being proposed as that
morality in some ways as a means for us
to secure Liberty and often in the the
section religion is framed as also being
useful to the securing of public order
immorality which also supports a natural
rights Republic but by making morality
and the kind of life that it presumes
Amin's this suggests that this this
particular condition is and or at least
could be subject to revision if we
perceive an alteration
the means of securing our ends of
personal liberty for example in an
example that that Wes gives us is that
marriage is supported at the time of the
founding as as needing support because
as he states it is it was considered an
important component of human happiness
if not for everyone then certainly for
the great majority considered a
component of human happiness but what if
with changes in our economic lives our
views of relationships etc marriage
fades as a vehicle that promotes our
happiness if people increase they can
increasingly conclude that marriage is a
limitation upon their Liberty if having
children is a limitation upon their
personality
if owning and using and disposing a
property as one wishes a central aspect
of the natural rights philosophy and
includes our own self we own ourselves
if that disposing of our property leads
us to conclude that I don't see my life
as bound up with a life of someone else
and the propagation of future
generations can the natural rights
philosophy answer the question of answer
the question and indeed propose and even
insist that you should get married and
that you should have children if the
ownership and possession and disposal of
our property ourselves leads us to
conclude that that's not what we want in
this section of the book again a very
compelling and striking section West
seems to conclude confuse what I would
regard as the dominant set of cultural
norms that arose in a in a condition
before arose from a set of beliefs and
practices before the institution of the
natural rights philosophy largely from a
Christian Way of life and Christian
beliefs and assumes that they would
those practices and beliefs would
continue in a seamless relationship with
the natural rights philosophy that would
do so then and that it would continue to
do so now and I think it was questions
were raised about whether that would be
the case then and those questions it
seems to me are more all the more
pressing now
those two some ways those two what
understandings that inherited that older
Christian tradition and the newer
natural rights tradition seemed
compatible as long as people's horizons
were not defined most fundamentally by
the natural rights philosophy that the
restraint of our rights aren't as
understanding of ourselves as right
bearing creatures had to come from a
source outside of the natural rights
philosophy and they to the extent that
we increasingly defined ourselves as
rights bearing creatures a kind of
solvent was acted upon those practices
and beliefs that lead in many
predictable ways to our situation today
now Tom Weston I might differ on our
analysis of the hopefulness that the
Constitution and its order might give to
us but I think we differ almost not at
all on many of our views about the
nature of our contemporary world today
and so the question in many ways is what
is to be done John Adams wrote that and
quoted by Tom West our Constitution was
made only for a moral and religious
people can we conclude today that this
Constitution was made for our people
today are we a moral and religious
people however we got to this point is
the natural rights philosophy a viable
philosophy for a people that are
arguably perhaps not anymore as a whole
as a large proportion a moral and
religious people and decreasing ly so if
studies are to be trusted
West suggests at the end of his book
that one can compare the natural rights
philosophy of our founders to the
Republic of Plato that these two seem to
offer options and as I read that I was
struck that maybe the comparison was not
in act because both seem highly unlikely
as being plausibly realized in today's
society so the question it seems to me
is that having presented us with this
perhaps ideal theory that no longer
seems to apply to our contemporary lives
and the world
especially the people to whom it is
supposed to apply perhaps Tom West and I
can agree a second volume is needed what
can we do to make a people worthy of a
constitution such as this
[Applause]
good morning my two on a thank Hillsdale
for inviting me before I say something
about Tom West wonderful book let me
start by noting the dramatic setting of
the last several generations of
scholarship in the academic world
there's a massive amount of literature
going back 40 or 50 years criticizing
the the liberal individual and offering
various directives this is a train that
has been written to tenure by two
generations of scholars so the
alternatives to this liberal individual
are are the the ancient man of virtue
and so a lot of Aristotle's scholarship
falls into this category
there's the medieval man who's concerned
with the common good and this is Aquinas
who is of course as some relationship to
Aristotle you have on the Left you have
his unalienable being of Marx who comes
after capitalism is finally destroyed
and so on the left you get this
criticism as well of the so-called
liberal individual and we should note of
course that because Marx never really
had any any purchase in America as Louis
hearts told us in 1955 the left version
of this Marxism is much more watered
down it's it takes a village you didn't
build that this sort of thing and then
you also have the communitarian man of
any number of scholars of the last
several generations who've tried to to
say that we can't have this thin liberal
self we have to have a thick and
embodied self in scholarship about the
American Founding has not escaped these
dramatic opposition's and so were the
founders liberals these individualist
liberals who built on Locke an earlier
liberal and are they both fatally flawed
because they have no substantive vision
of man was liberalism of the founders
partially corrected by this Republican
understanding that that are its inner
woven into this liberal view which saves
the foul
from the full development of this
liberal individualism I think professor
Jeanine is in some way raising this
question and I want to follow up on this
toward the end but but professor West
looked the political theory of the
American Founding refuses to take this
bait so to speak and finds in the
founders a comprehensive and rich
understanding of man and of the politics
that makes them flourish natural rights
theory is not an eviscerated liberal
theory with no substantive understanding
of the institutions and arrangements
necessary for man to thrive it's not the
theory that requires liberal
republicanism as a corrective in order
for the American regime to work well and
so the virtue of the book is it
discloses the philosophical coherence of
the natural rights and the law of nature
and more importantly goes further by
showing in rich detail what the moral
and economic Arrangements were at the
time of the founding and why they were
connected to the philosophy of natural
rights but there and I think lies the
difficulty of this wonderful book for us
the founders may not have been
disembodied liberal souls of the sort
that Americans seem increasingly to be
but retrieving them today for us is
difficult in proportion to whether they
had the substantive understanding of man
that the political theory of the
American Founding suggests that they did
hence the difficulty if the founders
were disembodied liberals like us it
would be plausible to easily set the
american republic on its foundation
again if the founders were not
disembodied liberals like we are today
the task ahead is way more difficult so
with the understanding that i want to
live in the world that the political
theory of the american founding sets
forth let me turn to some observations
from Tocqueville in the 1830s who i
think where which provides an
understanding of the profound difficulty
of the task
so from Tocqueville i'm gonna identify
three distinct problems that emerge
which i think speak to to us today first
what could be called men without history
natural rights theory presumes that we
can envision an original condition
constituted by God out of which we come
and produce a government but what if
Democratic conditions is total Qasim
which occur because we break the links
between man and man between man and
history and between man and nature
produce a kind of soul that has no
history no future no past a soul that
only lives in the moment and so can't
even conceptualize the whole idea behind
natural rights theory in democracy in
America in volume 2 part 2 chapter 17
Tocqueville says the following when once
these Democratic Souls have grown
accustomed not to think about what will
happen after they their life ends they
easily fall back into a complete and
brutish indifference about the future in
the past as soon as they have lost the
way of relying chiefly on distant hopes
they are naturally led to want to
satisfy their lief at least desires at
once and it would soon seem that as soon
as they despair of living forever they
are inclined to act as if they will not
live for one more day now anyone who
knows the 20th century political
theorist John Rawls will recognize this
because what Rawls who was the great
political theorist wholly endorsed by
the left starts with is a is a theory
according to which human beings have no
history and I think we have to raise the
question does Rawls this theory comport
with this new sort of democratic soul
that took they'll saw emerging already
in the 1830s a person who lives in the
instantaneous now are we all Rawls Ian's
now who are consumed by this a
historical need for fairness and I think
on the left that's where we are the
first problem is men without history the
second problem is what I call the unity
problem in volume two part one chapter
seven of democracy in America
Tocqueville says the following as
conditions become more equal each
individual becomes less like as fellows
more like as fellows weaker and smaller
and the habit grows of ceasing to think
about citizens and considering only the
people the folks if you want to use that
language
politics individuals are forgotten and
the species alone counts at such time
the human mind seeks to embrace a
multitude of different objects at once
and is constantly striving to link up a
variety of consequences with a single
cause the concept of unity becomes an
obsession the desperate search for
uniform rules if you will let me give
three manifestations and suggest that
these are fatal first what happens to
God when everything has to be unified
you no longer have an awesome God you no
longer have the Milton an awesome God
who is a Creator God remember the
fundamental distinction that you find in
Augustine is between God the create or
in the created world but as you become
fixed on unity that disappears so
therefore no sin no repentance no
forgiveness no divine gifts no mercy
this points to that what I'm going to
talk about at the end which is what I
take to be the great crisis of our times
the crisis of identity politics I'll get
to this in a bit so as we move toward
this world we're where there are no
awesome differences between creator and
created one manifestation we get is
Jesus is my friend the softening of the
distinctions between man and God but
next is the one that's upon us right now
the world is gaius body and the ghastly
confusion of Christian and
post-christian thought man must save the
planet can a chiral rights even be
thought of in such a frame of mind
second manifestation of the problem of
unity what happens between men and women
the denial of natural differences
entirely sex becomes gender the search
for a universal translator to overcome
the misunderstandings that men and women
have and so the book men are from Mars
and women are from Venus I take this as
a serious not the book is a serious
philosophical act but the desire to have
the universal translator so that we can
finally overcome the differences and
completely understand one another
can marriage a divine ordinance based on
these natural differences even be
thought of in such a frame of mind I
doubt it
third manifestation of the problem of
unity is federalism possible is
multiplicity within unity even thinkable
for a mind consumed by the idea of unity
so with respect to recent political
arguments before the Supreme Court
decided the matter in different states
about gay marriage it was inconceivable
for the Democratic soul to think that in
Utah they might conclude one thing in
Vermont they might conclude another and
that's okay and so we have to rush to a
uniform understanding and so federalism
is completely at risk if we're incapable
of thinking about plurals that boils
within unity and this of course nach
naturally polarizes national politics
and both political parties are more than
happy to oblige and take full advantage
of this his pluralism possible then
within Tok those democratic age I'm
haunted increasingly by Augustine's
remarks in the City of God book 19
chapter 17 where he's trying to suggest
that in fact the only way that you can
have pluralism if you understand is that
if you understand that unity is
something that's above the world of time
the City of God is at the end of time
and here in the world below we have to
live with different laws of different
nations and accept pluralism but what
took those saying is that this fixation
on unity makes us really incapable of
doing this this is why diversity is a
great sham because it really does rule
out true diversity it's a false unity
third the Equality problem this
desperate need for equality and so we
have the shift from IQ which does
separate people to EQ which perhaps
doesn't emotional intelligence we have
grade inflation we have too big to fail
we have climate change in order to save
the current evolutionary arrangements we
have global management food security etc
etc etc in short in the age of equality
failure is written out of the equation
of human life
professor West notes importantly the
Americans
that failure was necessary in order to
have improvement hence bankruptcy laws
go look at the section in the book it's
very important it's the recognition that
failure is inscribed into creation
itself the right to go wrong
so my provocation from the vantage point
of political philosophy might it be said
that the issue of sound money which is
well treated in the book and professor
West's also spoke about it just a few
moments ago is more than just an
economic problem
I suspect professor West agrees
injections of fur not currency into a
failing economy saves the existing order
of things it allows to live those things
which should have failed in evolutionary
terms fiat money currency injects
injections are the equivalent of trying
to keep alive the dinosaur ecosystem
after the great comet impact of the
Yucatan Peninsula some 65 million years
ago the founder set up an arrangement
where men had the right to succeed and
to fail malinvestment has to clear in
the democratic age and if not are we
destined for low growth rates as far as
we can see propped up by never-ending
injections of fiat currency all in an
effort to push toward equality to make
sure that nobody fails one more thought
that must be hurtled if we were to
return to and build upon the world the
founders set up the crisis of guilt in
America and in Europe the founders do
not much speak of guilt and sin in their
political writings because they presume
that this is largely a theological
matter not a political one for this
final obstacle I have to turn to
Nietzsche whose diagnosis of the crisis
of the West is I think right on even if
his suggestion for the antidote is
completely off so Nietzsche's wager is
the following the Christian world the
West is caught in a dangerous
intermediary condition between a
Christian and a truly post Christian age
Nietzsche says in the genealogy of
morals it's the church and not it's
poison that offends us meaning we modern
people who think we've escaped from
religion so the West retains the
trappings of Christianity
the love of democracy the love of
equality the idea of rights sympathy and
guilt without the overall architecture
within which it can make sense this is
the world of identity politics we have
eternal and unpayable guilt presided
over by a political party without the
possibility of repentance and
forgiveness and on another occasion
because it's not fitting here I would
make extended remarks about how identity
politics is a betrayal of Martin Luther
King because of Martin Luther King
understood was that while debts and the
great wound of slavery which has very
much to do with debt has a worldly
manifestation in the final analysis
guilt and debt can never be solved
through worldly political means alone it
also has to be solved through repentance
and forgiveness which are divine things
and so we've moved into this place where
we rejected the Christian architecture
but not the Christian thing called guilt
and this is the crisis of identity
politics and I can assure you having
come back from Europe where I taught
twice this summer that they are trying
out the Nietzschean option which is okay
we're going to give up on guilt we're
going to completely forget and we're
going to turn to ethnic nationalism
so this Nietzschean question about what
one does with guilt is I think a
profound question and we're going to go
beyond it in the way that Nietzsche
wanted or and I here I think reflecting
some of the things that patrick was
saying we're going to have to return to
the larger Christian architecture so to
conclude my list of obstacles that stand
the way of the return to the founders is
relatively short but they are formidable
ones and if I may submit will be decided
on the battlefield of religion rather
than on politics thank you
[Applause]
thanks to our panelists in a little bit
we are going to turn to the audience for
some questions but we do have some time
first for some exchange among the
panelists and I think going to ask dr.
West to offer just a few minutes of
reflection on some of the points raised
by by the other panelists and see if we
can get some discussion going dr. West
yes thanks
I want to thank both panelists for their
very generous comments on the book and
also quite thoughtful concerns and
questions that the book raises for each
of them I'll say something first about
Joshua Mitchell's Mitchell's marks on on
our contemporary situation and how the
book might or might not help or help
with understand what that is there are a
couple of topics that he mentioned which
I think are very much connected to the
two things the founders thought were
important in politics and which I didn't
say too much about in my initial remarks
one is God
there's unquestionably a very strong
theological dimension to the founding
which we see in the four references to
God and the Declaration of Independence
most famously the state constitutions
almost always begin with some sort of
reference to divine thanks to God thanks
for divine providence for making is
possible for us to create our own
governments not subject to tyranny and
despotism and when dr. Joshua Mitchell
dr. Mitchell says that that we got in a
sense of a being who is awesome it was
creative who over preside over the and
defined sin repentance Redemption
that God is as weakened if not
disappeared that's true and certainly in
the founding they thought insofar as one
could speak of God in official documents
as part of the founding that would be
the god of nature but for them the god
of nature was a God of moral authority
not just the so-called clock maker who
sets the clock in motion and walks away
but a being who creates a world of moral
rules and expects us to live up to them
this is especially and symbolized on the
back of the dollar bill in the picture
of the eye over the triangle the eye in
the Triangle emitting rays that
symbolizes divine providence and then
the words under it quite these over it
meaning he approves of what has been
started that's the way the founders
thought of God was judgmental being
providential and judgmental the approves
or disapproves and his Providence will
have an effect on human affairs secondly
the men and women distinction which he
which which Mitchell alluded to as
crucial I and that's this also goes to a
point which I'll get to when I talk
about Dean's comments but the men and
women yeah if you can't understand the
difference between men and women you
between smart and stupid between
virtuous and vicious if you really want
to say we're all equal and in the sense
that those distinctions don't count for
anything important
you can't understand the founders you
also can't understand what reality
that's not what life is and Mitchell's
right this desperate need for equality
in the sense of the finding away the
real differences now let me turn to
Denis n--'s comments the is there a
consensus that one can sensibly talk
about in the founding and he brought up
Denis brought up all the ways in which
there were disagreements true
my point was who won there are winners
and losers in politics the people who
objected lost I was looking at the
winners the anti-federalists lost and
therefore I don't care that much about
the anti-federalists any longer except
as a historical curiosity because the
Constitution we have was not the one
they wanted secondly on the subject of
the corrupting influence of the natural
rights that's something everybody in the
founding understood he quotes didn't
quoted some anti federalists in my book
I quoted John Adams and Alexander
Hamilton Hamilton has a nice quote on
that he says would you tell me how to
prevent luxury from producing effeminacy
intoxication extravagance vice in the
hop and folly
that's accuse me that's Adams meaning
once you have wealth you're going to
have those consequences and then
Hamilton made the very astute comment
true Liberty by protecting property
tends more powerfully again than any
other cause to augment the mouth mass of
national wealth which then means of
course the mischiefs of opulence will
follow Hamilton then says shall we
therefore on this account prescribed
Liberty no he says tis the portion of
man assigned to him by the eternal
allotment of divine providence that
every good he enjoys shall be alloyed
with ills except virtue alone you have
to be used to the idea that politics
can't solve all human problems
protecting individual natural rights
doesn't mean we're going to not have
luxury and wealth it means we will have
it and then we have a new problem but
you can't have life without good and bad
things going together third point and de
nimes argument he wants to say natural
rights means self ownership self
ownership means you get to define your
own idea of what's gonna make you happy
the
is the one thing the founders completely
disagreed with and deny for them natural
rights we're always within the confines
of a moral natural law that put limits
on natural rights including first of all
you can't harm others there's a moral
meaning to natural law that government
has to enforce and secondly when you
guard with regard to marriage it's the
natural law they as the founders
understood it that was supported
supportive of marriage and made and it
was based on this idea that Mitchell
brought up that there's a difference
between men and women you can't
understand marriage if you think men and
women go into marriage with the good
within that they're going to have the
exact same roles the so it's that
understanding of the founders idea of
equality was always equal natural rights
meaning the right not to be governed
without your consent by other human
beings not that you had the right to
define the meaning of your own existence
against the will of God in nature okay
thank you dr. West dr. nina dr. mitchell
would you like to respond to that or add
add anything I'm happy to turn it open
to the audience the audience okay thank
you
i Chris long so I guess my question is
to quote Alexander Hamilton to what
extent does Professor Dineen suggest
prescribing Liberty if he does
I guess one of the one of the issues
that debate is the question of what
Liberty is and at least in some of the
concerns that were voiced including in
this citation by Alexander Hamilton who
concludes we're going to have to live
with these vices and take our chances
and it would seem to me that we have and
maybe we haven't won but that Liberty is
not only understood and the freedom to
do as one wishes with one's property in
oneself even within the prescribed
limits of not harming others but liberty
is a form of self-rule and then the
classical and Christian understanding
one is not free if one simply pursues
luxury for example one is free when one
has the capacity to exercise self
control and self limitation when it
comes among other things to the material
goods of the world
I think the founders themselves
understood because they were so deeply
steeped in that in the Christian
tradition that this was the form of
Liberty that they should seek above all
and that no political community could
impose this successfully over time if
people didn't have this kind of self
direction and self discipline and self
rule so it seems to me there was a wager
that in the context of a political
system that would largely regard this
question as out of bounds that there
would be continued to be the strength of
that Christian tradition that would
discipline teach a kind of self
discipline again it seemed to me a wager
that was probably thought to be winnable
at the time of the American Founding
it's not as clear to me from the
perspective of some two hundred and
forty years later that we can draw that
conclusion quite as easily and
regardless of what the sources of the
corruption were it's clear there the
case that one couldn't hope to impose
from above some limitation on Liberty
certainly not on a population that would
be unwilling to impose those itself in
positions on themselves
I had a professor in law school who once
asked if God gave us natural rights
why doesn't he defend them my question
is do is a belief in natural law
necessary to us to act for the founders
to have devised the Constitution that
they did well there's two questions
there one is why didn't God protect the
rights he gave us if he gave us rights
and the second is do we need natural law
in addition to natural rights so the
first question is essentially why did
God create human beings who aren't just
born happy and stay happy forever I mean
Thomas Aquinas has a wonderful answer to
that question which I bet every founder
would have agreed with which is that if
we if we didn't have evil in the world
we wouldn't have anything to do we would
have we would be if you wouldn't have
virtue you can't have virtue without
vice you can't have intelligent
statesmanship without the possibility of
despotic statesmanship it is or quote
one of the quotes in the and you know
the famous quote from Franklin Roosevelt
that I mentioned in the book and was
mentioned also by one of the discussants
necessitous men are not Freeman says
Roosevelt and the founders basic
response was only through necessities I
mean I guess I remember this yeah now I
remember I quoted a letter of Abigail
Adams to her son saying it's only
necessity that brings forth great
virtues that's the only way you can
actually perfect yourself as a human
being by facing challenges and
difficulties so in other words that's
part of the way nature works and the
world that God made as for natural law
the idea of natural law which tends to
be forgotten by many scholars who write
about the founding is that there are
there is a moral meaning to Liberty it's
not that you get to do whatever you want
that you don't just own yourself in the
sense that
you can just do what you like with your
life and when pat dineen says that
liberty in the older christian sense
meant living according to living in the
right way
founders agreed with that you can't be
free unless you're following the proper
laws of your own nature which are not
laws of other human beings in the first
instance their laws that come from god a
nature okay good morning sirs my name is
mateo moran just had a question touching
on the topic a weap and you guys have
been discussing a little bit this
morning about wealth and you know that
relationship with republicanism know
that both Montesquieu and Hume both say
that Commerce is an inevitable extension
of republican government and that it is
necessary for Republican government yet
one of the issues obviously is the
corrupting influence of the pursuit of
luxury and avarice to a certain extent
and I think that one of the arguments
they make is that eventually this
pursuit will lead the people without
certain self control will then be at the
subject of being more at the whims of
the Wills of other men would you say
that today as a society we have reached
a point of no return in a regard where
we've kind of advocated that
responsibility of having Republican
government in the pursuit of luxury and
other greater material goods and have we
gotten to the point where we're no
longer fit for Republican government in
that pursuit which I believe some of the
founders said that you know it is a
possibility down the line if we follow
that route well I'll say something about
I don't know if you were directing that
to anyone in particular but I'll say
something about it and let others then
follow but the the reason why commerce
why the people in the founding commerce
was that was necessary in a free society
is because of the natural right to
acquire and possess property so that
naturally is often misunderstood to mean
that people were rich get to stay rich
and poor
get to stay poor but what the founders
meant by that right was not only the
right to keep what you have but to
acquire what you don't have and that
requires commerce that means you have to
have the right and the ability to go out
into the market and sell yourself sell
your labor that's what we do the first
time we get a job we go to a potential
employer I can do something that you'll
find useful and if you give me some
money that would be useful to me too
that's freedom that's what freedom means
and using your own talent and to get
what you need in life you can't have
that without without a society that
allows for Commerce and so now in which
then in turn means exactly as the I
quoted Hamilton saying eventually that's
gonna lead to national wealth which has
its own problems and we have to deal
with that but I have one other thing now
that I didn't mention before that was
alluded to by the Neen when he gave both
by both speakers actually by in their
remarks which is a big part of my book
maybe even the biggest section of the
book part two is on how government got
involved in the idea in the in the
program of promoting and sustaining the
right moral conditions for a free
society that turns out to be much more
of a robust thorough extensive program
than most people today are aware of
that's a part of the founding that is
mostly forgotten partly because it was
done by state governments for the most
part and not the national and especially
when you get into their marriage and
marriage laws and how they thought of
marriage and what they need thought in
government needed to do wasn't enough to
just say oh it's a Christian thing it's
fine you know Christianity will take
care of it no they thought government
that's a governmental thing because
who's gonna raise the children who's
gonna protect people when they're old
the family for them was a was a social
and therefore also a political
institution to protect people's rights
who protects the rights of children if
parents aren't there to love them and
care for them
that's why marriage was was supposed to
be why they made it so difficult for
them to be divorced and that was
absolutely an integral part now we today
say in the name of freedom we're gonna
let these kids what go to court and then
try to track down their
you know what were they gonna get their
money from go to welfare go to the
fathers who were no longer at home and
therefore no longer have an incentive to
give money that's those are the
alternatives that they would have bet
founders saw yeah the the concept that
most intrigued me from the discussion
this morning was the idea of failure and
the rejection of failure I think
politics science business is all based
on trial and error and if you refuse to
learn from that failure we're in trouble
and the most recent example of that
would be mrs. Clinton who completely
rejected any responsibility for her
failure and consequently will learn
nothing from it
so I was interested to hear you discuss
that concept of failure can I make a
quick observation so one of the virtues
of Tocqueville if you don't mind is that
he understands that life in the
democratic age is never going to be
parsimonious and in this particular case
he understood that that in the
democratic age we're going to be pulled
in two different directions on the one
hand we're gonna be need we're gonna be
drawn to equality and yet precisely
because we all have this thing called
middle-class anxiety we're gonna
desperately need improvement as well and
if you've read your Adam Smith you know
that malinvestment has to clear there
has to be failure and so what what I
think Tocqueville sees is that that
we're gonna be torn in these two
different directions and in point of
fact our political cycles might might
move in this direction or might accord
with this oscillation back and forth so
we'll have regimes that that think we
need to have a little bit of wealth
redistribution and then another maybe a
conservatives and come along and say no
we have to get rid of regulation and
we're gonna go around and around because
in the democratic age there's two goods
there's equality and there's and there's
a need for improvement because of middle
class anxiety well I have the floor if I
can just respond to this
Commerce observation but in a slightly
different way talk about the power of
money Tocqueville is hardly a Marxist
but he actually has this insight that
money becomes the measure of all things
the years before Marx has it in in early
philosophical manuscripts in and in the
Communist Manifesto in 1848 and what
Tocqueville argues is that as you move
from the aristocratic age to the
Democratic age you move from what could
be called an economy based on loyalty
and obligation to an economy based on
money where every every social action
has to be animated and lubricated by
money and I think his great concern and
now I come back to my first point about
non parsimonious Ness was are we going
to produce people who are who are wholly
consumed by this fixation on money or
are we going to produce people who
understand and this is perfectly
consistent with the theological
understanding that in fact there are
different domains of life that don't
always overlap so the question will be
the following do we live in a market or
do we go to a market this is a fateful
distinction and what Tocqueville worried
about was we would gonna we're gonna
produce people in the democratic age who
are incapable of making distinctions and
so think of everything in terms of money
so long before Marx said this
Tocqueville thought this was going to
happen so yes to Commerce but took those
worried about the complete fixation
about about money as we move into the
democratic age
I have a question for Matt yeah so
you've talked a lot about the failures
and difficulties with the regime of
natural rights I wonder if you could say
a little more about what principles you
would have added to the founding and or
what institutions would you have added
in substitution for the country for the
Constitution or in addition that would
have somehow perfected the founding and
made it what you think it should be for
example possibly an established religion
an established church that's all order
you know at least the founders got a a
week or two to create the Constitution
we have like three minutes I you know
that's that that's extremely difficult
question the the founders were dealing
with pressing questions of their
particular time of their particular era
it seems we're dealing with particular
questions of our particular era and so
in to some extent for me to imagine what
could have been done differently that
would have led to a different outcome
that's it's too engaging and interesting
theoretical question but it's one that
to my mind doesn't apply to our current
situation I don't know the answer I wish
I did
to what is to be done now it seemed to
me that the the the building blocks that
the founders had to deal with were a
fairly sound society a fairly sound
populace a populace of some moral vigor
and industriousness the willingness to
link guilt responsibility forgiveness a
populace that when they took the day off
for the Sabbath took the day off for the
Sabbath completely do we do we still
have a populace that has those kind of
building blocks
if we were to take Tom West book and say
okay let's do this right now do we have
the you know the humans the citizens who
are immoral and religious people or is
this just ideal theory like Plato's
Republic now as far as we're concerned I
guess you know to take a very modest one
modest stab at this and actually out
here I want to endorse completely at
least one aspect of the economic
argument of Tom's book to the previous
question about does is there a way to
think about economics somewhat
differently particularly in a republic I
would for conservatives I would really
like to encourage those who are
concerned with the moral religious fiber
of our nation to think about the ways
that our economy does or does not serve
that end or purpose if the economy can't
becomes a kind of autonomous entity in
the way in which professor Mitchell just
described we're no longer subjecting it
to those questions we're treating it in
some sense it's separate from those
questions in in toward the conclusion of
his book Tom suggests that there are two
aspects of the founders thinking that I
would endorse quite strongly the first
of these was to strenuously prevent
monopolies strenuously prevent
monopolies as affording competition as
well as forms of concentration of wealth
and it seems to me if we started doing
that it would be a massive improvement
of our economy because we would begin to
then encourage certain kinds of
competition certain kinds of failure
right monopolies is one way you protect
from failure interestingly particularly
in their buttress by the state the
second suggestion is that the founders
and I think it was widely viewed by
throughout throughout the founding
period that property in some material
real form should be widely owned the
actual experience of owning property and
working on property not in the abstract
form not in the form of stocks and bonds
not in forms of pieces of paper this is
because as of course Jefferson fameless'
famously pointed out to owned property
is to have a stake in one society
it's to understand the discipline that
comes with the ownership of property
it's a one-way we discover our mutual
actual need for each other it's through
the ownership and working of our actual
property and if we can think about ways
that we can structure our economy
markets are always structured but
structure our economy to achieve these
two ends so it seemed to me that would
be one way maybe it's a limitation on
freedom it's a limitation on monopoly
ownership and it's a form of structuring
the market that would encourage
widespread ownership of actual real
property I would regard those as
beneficial for a Republican society that
value self rule can I add to that we
have about a minute left so just and
then we'll get dr. Weston go ahead okay
yeah very quickly the you know in the
economy and the problem of inequality
okay so how about serious taxes on
outsourcing labor
how about serious tariffs on imports
from countries that have cheap labor how
about route tariffs rules that say any
country whose regulatory costs are lower
than ours then has to pay a higher
tariff I mean all kinds of ways you
could protect American workers and to
reestablish some degree of equality in
that way in America secondly in regard
to the decline of our current world
teddies question a minute ago
well our world is is the way it is not
because of the founding but because of
something else that happened in the last
200 some years and my I'll give you just
one piece of evidence for that since
we're almost out of time and that is if
you look at the history of Western
countries in the 1960s all of them went
through the exact same metamorphosis and
the same almost at the same moment and
so countries for example like Germany
and Britain that have long had
establishment of religion and official
churches and all the things that the
Americans didn't do all had that exact
same thing there was immediate
institution of no-fault divorce
throughout the Western world in the
1970s in almost every country immediate
institution of barriers on employers and
their freedom of contract with employees
there was a complete collapse of sexual
mores throughout the Western world all
at once whether it's New Zealand
Australia Germany England America this
is not due to the founding fathers I can
assure you of that this is something
where I want to go back to Josh Mitchell
Mitchell to conclude and it's his
comments about Nietzsche's diagnosis and
what's wrong with us that's where you
need to go to understand our current
situation it's a psychological malady
that is profoundly it is a profound
indication of a deep dissatisfaction in
the Western soul now that it has gotten
rid of God it has gotten rid of nature
and reason it has gotten rid of all
meaning in human life it has put us
exactly in the situation he said
Tocqueville worried about where we're
living in the present moment
that's where we are and that is not
something that the founding fathers can
be blamed for and I also agree something
the founding fathers probably can't
solve help us solve that's something
we're gonna have to solve ourselves and
I don't know how to do it either but
thank you very much
I think that's a fitting way to conclude
that's all we have time for our next
session will begin after a short break
thank you
[Applause]